right
and
please bear with us while we get our
events set up and the live streaming for
our
linkedin audience started
that will take me a moment
thank you for your patience as we get
this
process done
and
welcome
everyone on our webex session our
youtube and linkedin live streaming
sessions
to our expert webinar today
with ronald van loon the ceo of
intelligent world advisory board member
here at simply learn and
one of the world's foremost authorities
on data science and artificial
intelligence and today he's going to
speak about how data science is meeting
some of
the world's biggest business challenges
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn
just want to start with a
instruction on how to
enter questions for ronald
you put those in
the webex q a box
we also will keep an eye on the chat
but if you are watching on our streaming
services please put
your questions into the comments and
we should have some people who will
transmit those to us
with that i'd like to start with a poll
of our audience
and
if you are
on the streaming you might be able to
put the
answers in the comments but
this first poll is basically to give
ronald an idea of
who's in the audience today
so it's two parts one is what's your
current role
and
the other part is a check-in to see how
people are holding up we've been
going through some odd times in the last
two and a half years
uh we'd like to check to see how people
are
uh dealing with
the changes in the world around us so
give you another
20 seconds or so
and
here are the poll results
so ronald about half of the audience are
students today
um
and
the most
the other categories of people are in um
management or other roles
so this be an interesting session for
for folks today
and
so uh we can start by
introducing you
um as i mentioned
uh you're the ceo of intelligent world
i'll let you speak a little bit more
about yourself
who you are to the audience
that's great thank you thank you stuart
yeah i'm i'm ronald van loon i'm i'm the
ceo of the
intelligent worlds and we're going to
speak today about the intelligent world
in thousand worlds is a group of domain
experts that share their knowledge on
the platform and this is one of the ways
that we do that on a daily basis on
social and on the intelligent world and
i'm now more than 25 years in in data
analytics data science and machine
learning and ai and that's basically my
background and today we're going to dive
deeper into
let's say data science and especially in
in the role of all the bigger challenges
that that we see in in the market
so
we see many major challenges for
organizations which they're facing today
and
what we see as well is that
today's business landscape is quite
complex there's really a lot going on
that's that's contributing to
organizations experience business
challenges
and whether that's for example the
supply chain disruption or the data
transformation which is already going on
for for many many years
more hybrid
remote work environments but also the
collaboration between the people but
also because of this change you can
think about the skills and the skills
gaps that organizations have and they
need to recruit new people because of
all these changes so
businesses
they also have to to be prepared for the
impact of all different kind of external
events and then you can think about
things about changing political
landscapes or about new laws
or
regulatory landscapes or natural
disasters or political unrest or wars or
pandemic so there's so many different
things going on where organizations need
to be prepared for and data science is
playing an important role in this so
operating a business today i believe and
then if i look to my career in the past
27 years it's a lot more challenging
than ever before because we're entering
in in a new era of technology that's
been built on on the shoulders as i call
it the industrial age so as a result of
this impact of this industrial age
addressing environmental sustainability
has become of us one of the most
important issues of our time and
especially i think this year
i think we see it in europe we see it in
other parts of the world
climate is a very hot topic and also the
weather is contributing to this because
it's so dry
the last months that people really start
realizing hey what what's the real cause
of this and should we do something about
it so what we see with businesses
they are one of the costs for this
because businesses have a large carbon
footprint and they are responsible for
reducing the carbon emissions as set by
the paris agreements and this paris
agreement is an international accord and
commitment to addressing climate change
and limited the global warming warming
by
organizations and also by government so
organizations they must look to reduce
their environmental impact by reshaping
their organizations using new
technologies like data like analytics
like ai
and and have this managed in the cloud
to improve
all kinds of inefficiencies
and also to overcome outdated processes
and
outdated systems
so business at the same time they are
also responsible
for creating all kind of innovative
technologies and approaches that
contribute to improving this
sustainability such as through creating
technologies like electric batteries and
that reduce the energy consumption or
improving 5g network capabilities that
give organizations across industries
more capabilities to drive innovations
and we see now 5.5 g already developing
and coming to the market in two or three
years and as you can see
there was so much happening in this
modern business environment
it's up to us as people to learn as much
as we can about it
and then we can transition to new ways
of working and navigate our our new
intelligent world
and that's also let's say the the name
that i have for the network of
intelligence and thought leaders that
share their knowledge
so people
they are the
ultimately
ultimately the drivers for this change
and new industry-wide developments and
they are responsible for all the great
innovations that we have to today so
it's all about people whether
innovation sets like the smartphone what
is it now 15 years years ago
the personalized recommendations the
electric cars the automated warehouses
the wearable healthcare technology and
you can go on and on and on
so if we want to keep up
with this new data world and and this
business landscape
then we have to learn as much as we can
and educate ourselves in a way that
ensures that we are prepared for it
and a lot of you here are today
to learn about data science we saw
almost 50 percent
students
many managers who also think hey
if i have a more
data science skill set i can really use
that to become a better manager and also
drive my career so becoming a data
scientist and whether it's
a full-time data scientist or
learning the skills from a data
scientist this will help you about your
business about technology in all kinds
of new and exciting ways in which i will
share many many examples today and i
hope you you
find some that really fit with you and
i'm also here to show you
why data science is an integral part to
overcoming the most pressing challenges
of business that that our business is
facing today and
then how valuable data scientists are to
this success in the future of
organizations across all the different
industries to solve these type of
problems
and to to make it very simple data
scientists i think they are an integral
to operating in our new intelligent
world maybe even the foundation and
that's why choosing a career in data
in data science
is such a great choice
because it sets you up for a future of
success not only financially
but as data scientists can make
a six-figure salaries that's nice but
also for job security and so businesses
desperately need data scientists to to
solve their challenges and navigate
their business experiences
and also there there's a massive
shortage of available data scientists
out there so the demand for data
scientists is high
the supply is limited which is always
good for for the people who are data
scientists from a financial perspective
and from a demand and career opportunity
so there's a lot of opportunities to
become a data scientist and provide
value in all different kinds of
industries and different kinds of roles
and that's what we're going to discuss
today so data science
can
encompass a wide variety of skills a
wide variety of styles that are suitable
to your interest and you have to find
out what is the one that matches with
you so you can decide for yourself
the diverse the diverse set of skills
that you want to acquire
and and you work for what type of
company and what kind of industry that
captures your interest so that's
important and if you put in the work to
become a data scientist you will set
yourself up for a lifelong success it's
a foundation
for the coming 10 15 20 years in in your
career that you have all right so let's
jump now right into discussion and talk
about the value of becoming a data
scientist to solve this most pressing
challenges of organizations having to
today
so yeah
that brings up the question then uh
ronald what are
some of the most pressing business
challenges that you see out in the
environment today what are what are
as our title and
if i look to
the different markets the different
challenges um
and look from data science perspective
data science is the cornerstone for
preparing
for this imminent disruption that we
have and building a resilient future for
organizations and overcoming this this
most pressing business challenges that
we have today but
let's start with i think the key ones i
mentioned it already the key one is
environmental sustainability yes this is
one of the top business challenges today
and businesses need to transition to
technologies that promote this
sustainability
and all kind of new technologies
which are quite costly compare
to that of the legacy system that's what
we see what organizations are struggling
with especially if you have asset
intensive organizations that need to
change
and what we see for businesses one of
the challenges they must decarbonize to
achieve this net zero targets net zero
targets i might come back to it later
but that's the
2050 target that we have
but if we look to different industries
it's it's different per industry it's
different per sector you can imagine
that and for some it's more difficult
than for the other ones so for sectors
like aviation or for shipping
they're having a much harder time
achieving sustainability results in
progress or industries like
energy or transportation or
agriculture or construction they're very
emission intensive and they must make
more bold commitments and new business
models and new technology investments
and
changing their their whole mindset as
well and their whole business structure
so what we see is that many businesses
must approach
technology but also combining financing
and new business models and new
regulations differently
to achieve that net zero
the net zero
let's say threshold that we have
which we want to achieve by 2050
but if we look to this threshold in this
asset intensive industries it requires a
60 increase in capital spending on
physical assets compared to what they do
today so that's immense
and therefore we need to think
differently as well so organizations are
approaching for example renewable energy
technologies and and carbon capture and
carbon storage and and green hydrogen
fuels and
industrial electrification
as a means to support this deco
carbonization so building green
businesses is on the agenda of all these
business leaders to address this as 42
of the organizations are putting
sustainability as a center focus of
their of their proposition
but developing and scaling the screen
business initiatives is is quite a
challenge you can imagine if you're an
oil company and you need to change
that's a substantial challenge because
these physical assets investments
which are unrelated to the software
could cost billions
per per activity that you want to um to
deploy
and also there are many technology and
commercial risk to scaling
sustainability technology which also
requires a metadata
planning up to 2030 2040 and 2050. so
next to this most pressing challenge um
from this um
let's say from the the
the what we have in the environment is
also the supply chain i raised this
issue as well so you can think about how
supply chains have been heavily
disrupted as a result of the pandemic in
europe we have a conflict in ukraine
which really disrupts
many of the supply chains and these are
a perfect example of extenuating
circumstances that can't be predicted
and which are difficult to control
especially as an organization and as a
result of this
organizations they have been forced to
reimagine the supply chain operation so
they can be flexible and adaptable in
the phase of this disruption and they
need
insights into their operations into
their processes that bring them
visibility into this changing dynamics
and ultimately the supply chains have to
react to the high demands and the
ineffective logistic capabilities and
they need to adapt
quickly to this so organizations are
much more challenged
by by all these changing markets at the
start of the pandemic and everything
rapidly transitioned from offline to
online and many organizations needed to
discover how to operate this online only
and this impacts their service
capabilities
and
what they are prepared to deliver to to
their customers so it's also the final
product which has been impacted so
changing
consumer expectations and changing
consumer behaviors
we see they shifted then to online
especially after this
during this pandemic
now even as the world returns to normal
online
is still
hot it's not as hot as doing your during
the pandemic but it's still hot it's now
moving more to offline again
but what we see is that businesses are
rethinking the role of physical stores
and they're rethinking how to create
exceptional omnichannel experiences so
businesses are creating this the
seamless experience for customers
whether they shop online or go to a
physical store location and they come up
with all different kind of new concepts
and businesses have to learn how to
operate and how to navigate these online
experience is
better than ever because of these
changes and at the same time
organizations that have operated as
mortar stores
have to integrate online and offline
experiences but no matter what what
all the businesses have to deliver
personalized interaction across the
entire customer journey whether it's
online whether it's offline whether it's
any device it doesn't matter so
customers are moving
to digital more than ever and this quick
customer shift has forced organizations
to enhance the customer experience
across every channel and switch between
channels all the time
so despite this environmental
sustainability supply chains
changing market demands or
business challenges
they have other challenges too so we
briefly men managed
already how business landscape has
changed drastically over the last few
years so you can think about
technologies like data analytics and
artificial intelligence and clouds
they're really reshaping business
operations and the processes from the
ground up
and this affects as well
most of the people
because we are adapting these new ways
of working on a daily basis
and
today
people are getting used to working
differently like you can work
hybrids remote environments that we all
become more accustomed to over the last
couple of years since pandemic some
people even work in a different country
hardly travel to
um to the main office anymore
and
you also have probably heard about the
buzzword already for the last 15 years i
think is digital transformation
and this transformation helps
organizations to give the context into
how businesses are changing to support
the use of technology and this is not a
one day change it's it's a
many year type of change it basically
never stops as technology development
never stop and what we see is that
pandemic radius sped up these
organizations need to adapt to these new
ways of working and transform quickly
such as using new technologies to
respond to this disruption because
otherwise they couldn't
so businesses have to reshape their
organizations so they are flexible and
they are adaptable in the face of this
inevitable disruption in inevitable
changes
and this is a lot for organizations to
handle especially yeah the bigger you
are the of the the more complex it
becomes and they have to figure out what
technologies to use how to use data to
enhance their businesses and how to
train or acquire new talent like you
and this really only
scratches the surface of business
challenges and experiences today but
this is i think a broad look into what
modern business challenges look like
today
and i think without data science
organizations could not even achieve the
success that they have today or achieve
the competitive advantage that they have
today or create all kind of new great
innovations and new solutions and new
products and new services that we use
today so there's
absolutely
no way to navigate business challenges
in any industry
without data science data science as i
said i believe it's the foundation for
any business every businesses
a data business is an ai business
and that's what we're going to learn
more about today so stuart these are the
key challenges but really from a high
level and yeah we can
deep deep dive much more today
great
so
um and you've emphasized that data
science is the key to addressing these
challenges but
how
do we apply data science in some of
these situations what
what specific tools and
techniques
can be used to
address these challenges
yeah good question and i will dive into
a series of examples so if we look at
data sciences everything to do with
helping organizations
to overcome modern challenges if you are
a good data scientist
you can
solve
challenges because if you can solve
challenges you add value for an
organization so data scientists are an
integral part of organization's
capability to operate in this modern
changing business landscape
data scientists help
to establish the connection between the
the data the people and the operation
and the technology ushering these
organizations into
this digital era in this digital
transformation and data is an essential
component for for business of the
ability
to overcome all these challenges and to
adapt all the challenges to see all
all the changes that that are there to
discover these challenges and without
the data scientist so business can't use
machine learning to derive value out of
the data that leads them to great
success or to give them a specific
competitive advantage so organizations
they need data scientists to to
by improving their ability to deliver
all kind of next generation products
next generation services application
and and the biggest and the most
successful businesses
all have data science teams and
professional professionals working in in
all different kinds of capacities
whether it's from business whether it's
more in the data science and working
together
in different contexts solving different
type type of challenges and
organizations are increasing the data
science hiring efforts across the
industries so what we see for example is
from 2020 to 2021
organizations that employed 50 data
scientists or more have increased from
30
to almost 60 percent so on average the
number of data scientists employed in an
organization grew from 28
to 50. so it's it's um an area which is
really growing quickly and organizations
really recognize this as the foundation
for the future success
so let's use some specific and
interesting examples to demonstrate how
data science contributes to helping
organizations to
address these these challenges
i have a couple of examples
let's take one for example
about environmental sustainability
this is one is about michi bc heavy
industries and ibm they are developing a
platform designed to visualize and to
track co2 co2 usage
and which which is um very important to
track the co2 usage and without that
it's it's impossible for for these
organizations
with my voice
to track
um the crt uses using blockchain and
using ai
so this includes data visualization this
includes tracking co2 emissions in each
stage and matching co2 emitters
with companies that use it so this
provides supply chain
and provide new supply for new
applications in all different kinds of
industries
next we have been discussing supply
chain so supply chain often experience
disruption on different levels for
example and this is a little bit an
older one but i think it's a nice
example this is an example about toyota
and toyota reduced the production for
six months after the the tohoku
earthquake and the tsunami this was in
2011. so toyota decided to change their
production and the strategy by
re
regionalizing their supply chain so
another earthquake hit in japan in 2016
but this time toyota was able to resume
production
in just two weeks
due to this new strategy that they
boosted the company resilience and
promoted business
continuity
and data science was used
in this capacity to mitigate the risk to
evaluate the supply chain
vulnerabilities and to react to
unforeseen and unpredicted type of
events
i have one more case and this is watson
yeah probably you all know this this
retailer the beauty largest health and
beauty
retailer they focused on personalization
and on customer centricity to create a
seam lines seamless
online and an offline experience and
especially during the pandemic day they
changed a lot and they made investments
in technologies like data analytics and
social listening in enhancing data
management capabilities to experience an
enterprise-wide transformation
and especially focused at let's say the
customer experience and the customer
experience change so these three
examples they demonstrate
how data science is addressing modern
day business challenges whether
businesses need to use digital
technologies and platforms or better
react to
impact of this inevitable reception that
we see all the time or even to drive
personalization at scale to increase the
customer experience
let's let's dive a little bit more into
into this so analytics is transforming
the way that businesses operate at least
that's that's what i believe and if
if you can measure it
you can improve it and you can change it
so whether that's for marketing whether
it's for customer support whether it's
for manufacturing whether for sales in
every department basically
everywhere where you start tracking
start measuring it's it's changing so
analytics is also used to
to reduce bias in decision making and it
does that by studying the moves and the
outcomes of hundreds or even sometimes
thousands of different companies so
business can determine the likelihood of
different outcomes
and also better predict their success
rates
or for their own strategies and so using
all kinds of external competitive type
of data so just like our first example
with mitsubishi heavy industries and ibm
and the the environmental sustainability
where data science analytics and ai are
used for this solution to bring clarity
and insights into how and where co2
emissions where they are produced
so businesses are able to take further
action to reduce their carbon footprint
because
they make accurate decisions that have a
real impact on reducing the co2 which is
one of the the key goals
let's let's let's take a minute to think
more about this environmental
sustainability and the climate change
that we briefly mentioned already so how
data science is impacting that so data
science is being used
to make new discoveries
that address this climate crisis like
reducing greenhouse gas emissions from
electricity use
for example by using iot sensors on
utility equipment you can gather
data and optimize energy consumption in
supply chain in manufacturing to adapt
to control
of any process that optimize the
performance of the equipment so where
data
really drives the performance in
operations
remember our supply chain example from
toyota this is another example of how
data science analytics are helping
organizations to become resilient
and which is important so by using
analytics deoda is able to have a better
understanding of their supply chain
logistics and can improve planning
capabilities so that when a disaster
strikes which they can never predict of
course they are able to route production
to other facilities and determine the
best
course of actions for for keeping their
business operational or at least have
the downtime minimized as much as
possible so it's it's no different in in
the retail industry i believe if we look
to as watson
they are using data science and
analytics to better understand the
customer behavior
and where we see that the the market
dynamics were drastically changing after
the pandemic and this is
how this company was able to connect the
digital
and the physical world together
really rapidly change during this
pandemic and bring it better experience
to customers who shop online and who
shop offline and combine this and switch
between moving to online quickly moving
back to physical and combine this and
this strategy
i think is a lot more appealing to
customers because modern customers want
to feel a connected and personalized
experience to their brands whatever
channel they are wherever they are
connecting with a certain brand and and
even an international brand can can
transform
by building a customer focus strategy by
enabling
new business models and by using
data science so despite of all these
examples i think that we demonstrate
the impact
is clear
in many different industries to it so so
this is only a tip of the iceberg of
what data science can do to help
businesses to overcome their the most
pressing challenges that that we have
today
okay
so we have a question about
supply chains and that was one of the
big things especially
became
a topic of general
concern in the united states because we
kept hearing about disruptions to the
supply chain and seeing coverage of
you know container ships being
held offshore
because there just wasn't the ability to
to
offload them
so
this has flowed through the economy at
different times in different ways
for example in the united states we're
having a shortage of infant formula
so all of these issues are that people
hadn't thought about in terms of the
reliability of getting the products they
want and need
um
suddenly became top of mind so
why is supply chain such a difficult
problem to solve for organizations even
now
yeah and
you mentioned about the us
it's here in europe it's basically all
over the world because supply chains
have been disrupted
and
remarkable enough everybody would expect
oh um once let's say we we have this
pandemic it's changing
they adopt their
their supply chain and we can move on
and we get the supply
delivered
um i have a very funny example maybe not
funny but
i bought a new bike
almost two years ago i got a deliverer a
month ago
so
they were missing parts for such a long
time and the simple thing of a bike it
was an electrical bike
yeah that's remarkable yeah it was it's
so disrupted and we see it in the car
industry especially for example with
with the chips that that are there so if
one
element of your
product is missing
it can
really disrupt your whole delivery um if
you cannot replace it so we see that
these changes
due to the pandemic where factories
close it's not like oh
we just switched them on and off and we
just take another supplier these are
processes which are embedded and created
in in years they cannot change them so
quickly so therefore
data science becomes
more and more important to find out
where is the real issue
and and i think it's no secret that
supply chains challenges they are one of
the top challenges now
from organization because if you cannot
deliver a product it's out of business
so it's it's a critical part in your
organization and we see that the code
pandemic was really turning point in in
the supply chain and manufacturing
industrial history that forced
organizations to re-imagine their
operation and their processes so
businesses faced heavy disruption during
this time due to this unpredictable
nature of supply and demand
so
to give and give a couple of more
examples which are more in the industry
not for my personally
so if we look to the healthcare industry
they were struggling to manage their
inventory
when the demands were high for supplies
everybody knows about the mask
or even the vaccine which took months
and months to get the production running
and months later demand subsidized and
there were
there was an
excess of or certain supplies again um
here in the netherlands we have
um i think hundred million of masks
bought which they didn't use so even
some vaccines were getting lost as well
in
in tracking or they or they were
perished because of the health care
institution that couldn't properly
manage and store their inventory so
lots of challenges and businesses didn't
have the capability to react to this
disruption caused by this pandemic and
they couldn't be
resilient in the face of this new type
of challenges and businesses and supply
chain industries
today they are already struggling from
this economic impact of this pandemic
and still struggling and seeing this
this impact and i think if we look at
this and on top of it all the conflict
in ukraine has made supply chain chances
even even worse that that we see
um
there are critical equipment there are
material shortages uh they are strange
on global food supplies and especially
i'm not 100 sure but i think that 40 of
the grain comes from ukraine and
we had 40 percent of the gas in europe
coming from russia which is now step by
step
basically shut down so
immense impact and so this green
conflict has even impacted energy trade
and as especially than over here in
europe i'm not sure the effects in in
the us or in the rest of the parts of
the world
so keep in mind that organizations
across the globe
need to reduce the carbon emission um
and we all need to work on this becoming
net zero but but now there's even more
uncertainty as this weather can be
effectively achieved with these type of
challenges and with these type of wars
energy
crisis etc so there's so much volatility
in and businesses and governments are
seeking solutions to become more
resilient with all these changes and
what we see is that
effective government and business
responses are an integral part of
overcoming these effects of of covert 19
of
sowing energy prices and crisis of
achieving sustainability so
companies
they they we see that they're even
dealing with labor shortages across the
supply operations right now um
there's
basically they say overhead it's the
other way around you don't apply for a
job the the people from the
organizations come to you to apply for
you
and that's that's how bad it is over
here so this reforces organizations to
reimagine staffing and reimagining their
hiring processes
and then this all helps helps them to to
allocate and deploy certain staff
members
where they are are most needed
as a result of the supply chain labor
shortages
organizations also have to to rethink
recruitment have to rethink
management capabilities to improve their
labor planning and as many as say i
thought 14 today is have a management
background this is something really to
keep in mind
and
organizations really need to effectively
monitor and measure supply chain
vulnerabilities to understand
the supplier risk as well
so do you have one supplier multi
supplier where are they located what are
the risk and find exactly
where the disruption originates in the
supply chain how can you replace it how
can you quickly detect it
do you have stock somewhere else how to
quickly restock so there's all kind of
questions that immediately occur
once there is one disruption
somewhere and at the same time
organizations have to expand their
existing knowledge to understand the
physical the political the the social
risk that they face in this complex and
diverse supply chain operations so they
deploy new solutions like digital alert
systems that help them to focus their
attention on on the risk areas and the
regions of of the supply chain to
if something happens to act immediately
and try to reduce the
the damage
and what we see as well is that
companies are looking at core areas of
for the supply chain vulnerabilities and
this includes visibility into the
suppliers
much more deeper than what they did
before the supplier from the supplier
and from the supplier so to get in-depth
insights in your supply chain
so you can improve your planning
accuracy you can enhance manufacturing
performance because if you have no
supplies there is no manufacturing um
you can address all kinds of product
complexities if if
elements are missing if the chip is
missing for example
also it impacts safety it impacts the
delivery performance it
impacts your stock
all kind of let's say elements that are
impacted and
in the end we need to have a mind shift
for the organization and to think how to
get a resilient supply chain so
responding to supply chain
vulnerabilities like these require
significant structural changes using
resilient metrics resilient insights
into the data
and act upon the data
very quickly if something happens in
your supply chain and it's not only
direct your supplier that's the supplier
from the supplier from the supplier so
stuart this is why supply chains
challenges i think are still on the top
of the list of the business leaders and
they will be for a long time because
they will not go away
yeah and and that brings up a question
that uh that came up also in the q a
stream um
so
we see the challenge
how what are the ways that
data science and data analytics
get applied
to the situation with supply chains for
example
how can
businesses use these tools
to
get insights into how their supply
chains are and are not working and how
to restructure them to be more resilient
yeah yeah so if we look from a higher
perspective data analytics i think is
the reason why organizations are
successful in the in overcoming their
specific supply chain challenges if you
have no proper data analytics in your
organization forget about solving your
your supply chain
challenges so organizations they are
using data science and they're using
data analytics to innovate and to
improve the resilience and and to
overcome
their disruption and their changes and
data analytics can bring
more visibility into your supply chain
process and into your operations and as
i said it's not your first line supplier
it's the supplier from the supplier from
the supplier and supply chain is not
only yeah who produces it but
um there let's say
their raw materials are these raw
materials delivered or is there an
impact on on on this already so what is
the impact and for your supplier from
the supplier um
can they still deliver that their
product so you need to have
in-depth
insights in your full supply chain from
from all the
all the companies basically that that
are involved so business can see the
full
extent of their logistics and they can
adjust their routing they can adjust the
planning if needed and avoid shipping
and production delays in the end and
avoid that they don't have stock to to
sell
so there are short and all kind of long
term impacts from production delays or
from from changes in customer behavior
as they move from from products to
services
like what we have seen in the impacts on
the pandemic and what we've seen in the
ukraine conflicts and what has brought
so
there is data analytics is helping the
organization strictly to
reform
and to address
immediate disruptions recognize
disruptions give a notification and so
actions can be taken and prepare for
future disruptions too although not
everything can be
forecast not everything can be predicted
especially for example with wars or
floods or other type of activities which
are
unpredictable for us and organizations
they are using analytics to improve and
to manage the coordination between all
the teams between all the departments
between
all the supply chain partners to enhance
the organizational widespread response
to this disruption so data is is core
sharing this data is core
to respond and to be resilient and to to
know the type of impact
so for example companies can better
manage their inventory and they can
manage better manage their critical
materials
um
for example if you look to tesla they
did quite well in managing their chips
and where other manufacturers were
lacking this and they couldn't deliver
the cars that there was a high demand
but they couldn't deliver
what we see as well is that businesses
can examine risk associated with the
supply chain networks and
with their manufacturing process and
with the labor
and pinpoint
which area is likely to be most impacted
from the disruption if you don't have
the people yeah you cannot deliver if
you don't have the raw materials you
cannot deliver if your machine is
breaking um you have an outage you
cannot deliver
then we have for example iot um iot is
used in combination with other data
technologies across the entire supply
chain to
to sense and to detect all kinds of
upcoming disruptions early so to give a
little bit of examples
if we look um
the health of physical equipment and the
health of machine parts on a factory
floor
they
add iot sensors and these sensors can
collect data that fed
back to the supply chain operations and
organizations can use this data to
determine where the machine parts are
wearing down or about to break
also very important to to know
what's happening and business then can
send technicians to service these parts
quickly
to avoid a costly breakdown to their
equipment or even worse at a downtime in
the whole production process
so this is called predictive maintenance
it's it's nothing new but it's an
important part in your supply chain
insights and to take them part of the
overall insights to manage it and if for
your maintenance for example parts are
not available due to
these pandemic changes
you should be aware of this because it
can impact your production line and in
the end the delivery and the sales of
your products
so these are more practical examples of
of how to put into context the impacts
of data science the impact of data
analytics of iot type of data
that
are used
to overcoming supply chain challenges
and it's complex because it's not all
your own company it's the supply chain
insights from third parties and
suppliers from your your third party so
it's it's very complex and very
sensitive to share this data as well
and if we then take a deeper look at the
supply chains and data science
organizations are really reimagining the
supply chain performance they are
reimagining the supply chain
functionality and they are changing the
very nature of how traditional supply
chain control towers operate
by enhancing everything with digital
technology so so this is an idea of
digital end-to-end
control towers that connect all the
different silo systems all the data all
the operations like a network and then
even in your supply chain
this is
ideal for managing your supply chain
disruption so for example a delay
in in transit
heading for for certain location could
trigger notification
approximate the the impacts of a
production shutdown
make adjustments to the production
schedule and then notify the logistic
manager and this is all take place in a
matter of minutes
but this can prevent you
from
um a supply chain issue or delivery
issue and then this type of technology
is
revolutionary i think for the supplies
and operation and became
yeah
really core for each supply chain and i
think it's a great example of how data
science and data analytics and iot all
come together to deliver this next
generation of supply chain experiences
and supplies and insights and even start
predicting
supply chain issues and solve them
before they even happen
so this has major impact
on how businesses can optimize
their responses to any situation such as
by enhancing end-to-end planning
by connecting these previously isolated
functions through the planning and
logistic processes but also
do that for the the the partners and the
suppliers of the partners they do it by
enhancing their decision making using
advanced analytics to measure the
outcomes of different responses to the
disruption or even change their
operational models entirely
and rethink how to use technology how to
use the people and processes and can
change to support to to new what we call
industry 5.0 solutions so
i think this is an example of
that we all yeah that we all can can
imagine um
shortly after pandemic everybody knows
nike nike enhanced their supply chain
technology initiatives by using
radio frequency identification rfid
this type of technology to improve the
tracking it's nothing new but they used
it and they used predictive demand
analytics to reduce the effects from
the stores closing in china to use this
these products
reship them to other online channels and
basically sell them quickly in other
in other countries
by using their insights by this rfid
technology so sure this these are just
some of the many examples how data
science and analytics solve
all different kinds of supply chain
problems
yeah and one of the questions that came
in was you know is this only applicable
to business or is there broader scope
but certainly as you mentioned
you know there's a huge issue in europe
with the disruption of the supply chain
of energy
due to the conflict in ukraine and the
political
conflict with russia
so when you look at
using data analytics
to look at all the different sources of
energy available in the european market
all the different places that they can
draw from
and also all of the different ways the
energy is being used in the seasonality
of demand and how much more demand there
will be for
energy for heating in the winter and so
forth
these types of things require complex
um
analytics and data science modeling so
that you can
come up with strategies to deal with
disruptions what if
the
supply of gas from russia is never
extraordinary yeah and especially this
what if now indeed becomes um what if
not and there's there's a lot what if
not there's yeah it was a 40 delivery by
russia from the gas now
we need to take into account there is
zero
maybe there is some maybe not but that's
let's say not
and then it's the question
what can we do so there's many different
options it's not only
trying to allocate new energy sources or
find new gas or allocate certain gas
but it's also how to reduce your energy
consumption
and how can use data we use data for
this or how to use all the solar panels
on the different houses to
deliver part of the energy at the right
time
um in in the coming months and to solve
a part of the problem so there is
data and on the other hand has finding
energy sources
that you need to solve it and and
to do it we need great people we need
data scientists and we need people that
have built a career in data science and
can help these organizations
yep and and
that brings up you know a central
question which is
a number of people have asked
along the way here in the webinar
what types of
educational path or road map can they
follow and what kinds of
data science careers can they possibly
aspire to
yeah so
if you look broadly
energy consumption is basically
everywhere in every product that you
create that has the user's energy
you can help
you can reduce the energy consumption
you can find new ways with the help of
data
so
there's really a pleathora of
possibilities here so data scientists
what we see in general they help
businesses to make the connection
between the operation between the
processes and technology and
offer the insights and the predictions
that help organizations to react and to
overcome all kinds of challenges and
drive competitive advantage that's the
high level
let's say
way that data scientists contribute and
if you then look to your career path as
a data scientist
we see that this is is evolving um
what you can see is that you can get all
different kinds of job roles and what we
see step by step that data gets
important in any job role in any
responsibility
no matter which business no matter which
industry that that you work in so
if you have in in your mind and as a
mindset that you continuously need to to
learn and educate yourself and you need
to advance your career in data science
and you have these skills whether you
are learning to to operate new
technologies or new programming language
or use different platforms you can use
it in basically any situation whatever
job you do it's some kind of basic skill
like communication is a skill but having
data science is a skill as well that you
can use in in any situation in any job
in any role and there are many different
types of data science career and
educational opportunities for people to
pursue that are integral to
aiding a business and overcoming a
challenge that they face
in today's digital world so if there's a
challenge
and you have data science skills you can
help better than just doing it on good
feeling or based on experience you can
help them in decision making with the
help of data
next to that for example we have
technical skills that are required for
data scientists
what is important like you have you're
learning programming language here you
need to learn and then there's many
students over here
like python or sql and you can use
platforms
learn hadoop learn about apache spark
learn about data visualization like
tableau or power bi or enhancing your
machine learning an artificial
intelligence knowledge by by deepening
your understanding of neural networks
and natural language processing so
really look at yourself where are you
what are your steps what are the steps
you need to take what are the business
in what what do you like
so
we see that a lot of people think the
data scientist is just sitting behind
the desk on the computer and only
require the technical sales to provide
his business
business value but i think
it's totally opposite so if if you're a
good data scientist and you really want
to deliver
business value
data scientists need to become more an
analytical thinker
in order to identify these unique
industry trends and challenges to
overcome real-world business scenarios
so the more you have your food on the
ground
in the business the better you can help
the business with your
analytical thinking so you have to
understand what business is going
through and the experience and the
challenges across the industries
in order to provide real value and
if i was in your shoes look at okay what
experience do you have already as a
student
what what do you love what topics do you
love what industries do you love do you
have specific
companies where you want to work with
and what type of department one do you
want to work in and you these four
metrics already the combination gives
you already so many different
possibilities and opportunities
and and
next to that if you look to a data
scientist they're not an individual so
you should be a team player so that's
another skill which is important that
you need to collaborate
with different people on different
projects and take your role take your
specific niche role in
in a certain group in a certain team in
a certain department and
the better you can communicate with both
business and i.t
the more it's going to help you to to
bring and communicate this this business
value
whether you can talk to c-level
executives to i.t managers to your team
members so
i was talking about communication i
think communication is a great important
skill
for anybody and especially if you can
combine with data science skills your
your goal for for a company um and then
there's the mixer of course just between
technical and non-technical type type of
of skills so there's there's many
different career paths for data
scientists
um
you can
move from from let's say a role
perspective you can be a machine
learning engineer you can start as a
data analyst or move more in the
technical part as a data engineer or
more as an architect a data architect or
a business id analyst
so
many many different possibilities
based all on
on your own skill sets on your own
wishes
and
yeah i just
we discuss now the most pressing
problems these are for sure areas
where where you can
dive into
um
as a data scientist as a data analyst
and where there's a lot of demands but
as i mentioned every department every
industry
every
role you can find find the challenge
with your data science skills but there
are specific skills and i'm happy to
yeah to help you
answering your questions that you have
with regards to this and see if we can
help you
driving your career moving forward
with the help of these type of
challenges that we see in the
in the industries in the different
companies steward
are you there
i am i am here
do you have questions
yes we have a lot of questions um but uh
we don't have time for all of them but
i'm going to start with a question from
amit
who um since we have so many students in
the audience what what would you suggest
to a person with
maybe less than a year of experience in
the it field
what kind of path can they follow
um to become a data scientist
yeah so
first ask yourself what is the defining
direction that you wanted data
scientists there's many different roles
but what i always like as a start is
start either as a data analyst so
depending on on your skill and the
experience that you have as a programmer
um and if you've done already certain
education as a data analyst or as a data
scientist or start as a junior data
scientist or just start
an education next to your job
and
build some experience and run some cases
there's so many cases available
everywhere
on different
great sources